In this lesson we're going to learn how to use
memcache in App Engine applications. One good thing about using
Objectify is that you can configure it to automatically use
Memcahce to cache your entity data. All you have to
do is add @cache annotation to your entity class. Then
Objectify is going to do its best to use Memcache
whenever possible when you try to get entity data, to
reduce hits to the data store. It's really easy to use
Objectify with Memcache, but there's a few things
that you should know about how Objectify uses
Memcache. For one thing, it only uses Memcache
when you get an entity by key, you save
it or you delete it. And query results
are not cached. Objectify puts the property values into
memcache. It doesn't put the entire entity into
memcache. Another thing that is really helpful to be
aware of is that objectify has its own session
cache. So often when you do a get by key,
objectify is going to get the results from the session cache
without even going to memcache, let along going to the
data store. So here's what the profile class looks
like with the @Cache annotation. All I did was add
@Cache to the entity class definition and now objectify is
going to use memcache to cache property values whenever possible.
I don't even have to write a single line of
code to do it. So when you're applications been deployed
to app spot, you can use the memcache viewer to
view the memcache entries. I'm going to flush Memcache, to make
sure, that I have no Memcache entries to start with.
So now I have no entries in Memcache, I'm going to
go and do some things in my application, to see
if I can get some Memcache entries. When you go
to the profile page, it gets your profile entity out
of the data store if you already have a profile.
That's how it knows what your display name and tee
shirt size are. Here on the profile page, I'm going to
make a change. Change my tee shirt size, and update
my profile. I'm also going to go to the Show Conferences
page and show all the conferences. The list of conferences
is retrieved as a Query and as I already mentioned,
objectify doesn't use Memcache for Query results. However, we do
actually get the profile entity by key so we can
figure out the display name of the organizer. I can
also drill down into conference details. Which does a get by
key. So now I've done a few things that involve
getting entities by key from the data store. Let's see
if any of the results got cached in Memcache. So
you need to be sure to refresh the Memcache viewer to
get the latest data. And here you see there are
some Memcache entries. I've actually only got one item. And I
thought maybe I would've had a few more than that. The
reason there might not be as many items in Memcache as
you expect, is because Objectify has its own session cache. So
it's going to save data in the session cache, which will reduce
the use not only of Memcache, but of the data store.
So anyway, you end up seeing less items that you mark
with the Memcache viewer, because of the session cache. So
go ahead and update the conference and profile empty classes to
use Memcache. It's a good practice to always check any changes
to your app on localhost first. So feel free to do
that. And you're going to need to deploy to appspot, because
we want to use Memcache viewer. And for that, your app
has to be running on appspot. After you've deployed your app
to appspot, go to the Memcache viewer, and if you have
any items in Memcache, you might or you might not.
But if you do, go ahead and flush Memcache. Then
in your application, go ahead and do some things to
put some data into Memcache, so create some conferences, show
conferences, view details, maybe create or change a profile. And
then go back to the Memcache viewer and see if
you've got any entries in Memcache. You might need to
do a few things in your application to get some entries
to show up. And you'll probably less items in the Memcache.
Fewer than you might expect because Objectify uses it's own session cache.